NEW YORK NOW.
>> Sean: THANKS, TUCKER.
GREAT SHOW.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT IN LESS THAN 24 HOURS,
DEMOCRATS WILL PUT THE WORK OF
YOU, THE AMERICAN OF PEOPLE ON
HOLD TO CARRY OUT ONE LAST SMEAR
OF FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP OR JIM
ACOSTA SAID, PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
EXILE
EXILE.
INSTEAD OF GETTING AID TO
WORKERS OR CREATING A PLAN TO
SAVE SMALL BUSINESSES TROUBLE,
WELL, CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS
WILL BE BUSY THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE CONDUCTING SO MANY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IMPEACHMENT
CHARADE SHOW WITH A VERDICT THAT
IS PREDETERMINED.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE
ACQUITTED.
45 STATERS HAVE VOTED TO END THE
TRIAL BECAUSE IT’S NOT
CONSTITUTIONAL.
BY THE WAY, THE SENATE HAS NO
JURISDICTION OVER A PRIVATE
CITIZEN THAT WOULD BE DONALD
TRUMP.
NOR CAN YOU REMOVE A PERSONAL
FROM OFFICE THAT HE NO LONGER
HOLDS.
BUT IT DOESN’T MATTER TO THE
DEMOCRATS.
THE MEDIA MOB IS LIVING IN THEIR
RAGE-FILLED FANTASY LAND.
IT LIKE A DRUG.
THEY CAN’T GIVE IT UP.
THEY CLIMB THAT DONALD TRUMP
INCITED THIS INSURRECTION
JANUARY 6 WHEN HE SAID THINGS
LIKE OH, FIGHT LIKE HELL.
LIKE EVERY DEMOCRAT LIKE WE’VE
BEEN SHOWING YOU FOR WEEKS.
NOW APPARENTLY THE MERE USE OF
HYPERBOLE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
EVEN USED THEMSELVES IS GROUNDS
FOR IMPEACHMENT IF THAT NEW
STANDARD, IF THAT’S IT FOR
EVERYBODY, WELL, WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO ABOUT MAXINE WATERS?
YOU DECIDE.
>> YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET, IN A RESTAURANT, IN AN
APARTMENT STORE, AT A GASOLINE
STATION, YOU GET OUT AND YOU
CREATE A CRY.
YOU TAKE BACK ON THEM.
YOU TELL THEM THEY’RE NOT
WELCOME.
>> THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TURN
ON THEM.
THEY’RE GOING TO PROTEST.
THEY’RE GOING TO ABSOLUTELY
HARASS THEM UNTIL THEY DECIDE
THAT THEY’RE GOING TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT NO, I CAN’T HANG WITH
YOU.
>> THE LYING PRESIDENT SAID I
HAD THREATENED ALL OF HIS
CONSTITUENTS.
I DID NOT THREATEN HIS
CONSTITUENTS, HIS SUPPORTERS.
I DO THAT ALL THE TIME.
I DIDN’T DO IT THAT TIME.
>> WITH THIS KIND OF
INSPIRATION, I WILL GO AND TAKE
TRUMP OUT TONIGHT.
>> Sean: GOING TO TAKE TRUMP OUT
TONIGHT.
YOU CAN SEE, FOR YEARS, MAXINE
WATERS CALLING FOR VIOLENCE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HIS STAFFERS AND
EVEN HIS SUPPORTERS.
SHE TALKED ABOUT TAKING HIM OUT
AND USING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY’S
OWN LOGIC AND STANDARDS.
THAT WOULD WARRANT IMPEACHMENT,
RIGHT?
UNTIL NOW, SHE’S NEVER FACED ANY
IMPEACHMENT OF ANY KIND.
THE DEMOCRATS VOTED HER TO BE
CHAIRMAN OF THE POWERFUL FINANCE
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
THAT’S ACCORDING TO WATERS
HERSELF, SHE’S DONE NOTHING
WRONG WHATSOEVER.
TRUMP INSURRECTIONIST, HERS IS
PEACE, LOVE AND KINDNESS, WHAT
YOU HEAR ON SUNDAY MORNING IN
CHURCH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY’RE GOING TO TRY TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE DONE RALLIES, AND
WE’VE SAID THING THAT HAVE
INCITED OTHERS.
>> CAN YOU SAY YOU HAVE NOT
GLORIFIED OR ENCOURAGED VIOLENCE
AGAINST REPUBLICANS?
>> ABSOLUTELY I CAN SAY IT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, IF YOU LOOK
AT THE WORDS I USED, THE
STRONGEST THINK I SAID IS TELL
THEM THEY’RE NOT WELCOME.
TELL THEM.
TALK TO THEM.
I DIDN’T SAY GO AND FIGHT.
I DIDN’T SAY ANYBODY WAS GOING
TO HAVE ANY VIOLENCE.
CAN THEY CAN’T MAKE THAT
STATEMENT.
>> Tucker: CREATE A CROWD.
TAKE TRUMP OUT TIED.
GET IN THEIR FACES.
FOLLOW THEM IN THE GROCERY
STORE.
WE HEARD THE VIOLENT RHETORIC,
WHICH ACCORDING TO THE DEMOCRATS
OWN STANDARDS THAT IS INCITEMENT
TOWARDS INSURRECTION.
WE HAVE TAPE FROM CHUCKY SCHUMER
THREATENING TWO U.S. SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES THERE ON THE
STEPS OF THE U.S. SUPREME COURT
BUILDING SAYING "THEY WON’T KNOW
WHAT HIT THEM AND THEY WILL PAY
THE PRICE."
WHEN DOES HIS IMPEACHMENT TRIAL
START?
WE HEARD CORY BOOKER SCREAM, "GO
TO THE HILL, GET OUT AND PLEASE
GET UP IN THE FACE OF THESE
CONGRESS PEOPLE."
HE’S INCITING INSURRECTION.
WE HEARD JOE BIDEN TALK ABOUT
TAKING TRUMP BEHIND A GYM AND
BEATING THE HELL OUT OF HIM.
I WONDER IF A CONSERVATIVE SAID
THAT ABOUT HIM WHAT WOULD THE
REACTION BE?
OVER THE SUMMER, DAYS AFTER A
MINNEAPOLIS PRECINCT BURNED TO
THE GROUND, VIOLENT RIOTS
WREAKING HAVOC WHAT DID KAMALA
HARRIS SAID?
SHE WAS ENCOURAGING MORE OUT.
TELLING STEPHEN COLBERT, THEY’RE
NOT GOING TO STOP.
BEWARE, THEY’RE NOT GOING TO
STOP.
WHAT?
BURNING DOWN POLICE PRECINCTS?
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO STOP BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
ELECTION DAY IN NOVEMBER.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO STOP AFTER
ELECTION DAY.
YOU TAKE NOTE OF THAT ON BOTH
LEVELS.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO LET UP.
THEY SHOULD NOT AND WE SHOULD
NOT.
SOUNDS LIKE INSURRECTIONISM.
APPLYING THAT DEMOCRATIC
STANDARD TO WATERS AND SCHUMER
AND JOE AND KAMALA HARRIS AND
PELOSI AND OTHERS, ALSO
PROMOTING BY THE WAY IN HARRIS’
CASE A BAIL FUND TO GET VIOLENT
RIOTERS ARRESTED OUT OF JAIL.
OKAY.
I GUESS THEIR IMPEACHMENT TRIES
WILL FOLLOW.
NOW ACCORDING TO THE FBI AND
INVESTIGATORS AND ACCORDING TO
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN RELAYED
TO THE COURT DOCUMENTS AND EVEN
ACCORDING TO ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, THE BREACH AT THE
CAPITOL, OH, IT WAS PREPLANNED.
IT WASN’T SOME OUT OF CONTROL
SPONTANEOUS INCITEMENT TO RIOT
BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP’S
REMARKS.
IN FACT, WE’RE NOW LEARNING THE
TWO PIPE BOMBS THAT WE HAVE ON
VIDEO THAT WERE PLANTED THE
NIGHT BEFORE MAY HAVE BEEN PART
OF A PREORGANIZED ATTACK.
SO MAKE NO MISTAKES, AUTHORITIES
WERE WARNED ABOUT AN IMPENDING
WAR AT THE CAPITOL.
THAT WAS BEING PLANNED.
PERHAPS WEEKS IN ADVANCE.
THIS IS QUESTION YOU DON’T HAVE
SNAP IMPEACHMENTS BEFORE YOU
HAVE ANY FACTS, ANY
INVESTIGATION, ANY CONCLUSIONS.
NEVER MIND THE IDEA THAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO ALLOW THE OTHER
SIDE TO AT LEAST MAKE THEIR
CASE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
DEADLY INSURRECTION AT THE U.S.
CAPITOL ADDED NEW EVIDENCE THAT
IT WAS PLANNED.
>> ALSO SHOCKING, NEW REPORTING
THAT THE FBI RECEIVED A SPECIFIC
WARNING BEFORE THE RIOT.
>> THE FBI WARNED OF WAR AT THE
CAPITOL.
FOR SOME REASON, SECURITY WAS
NOT STEPPED UP TO MEET THE
CHALLENGE OF THAT ATTACK.
>> IF THERE WAS AN INTERNAL
PROBE BEFORE.
>> THE FBI ADMITTED THAT PEOPLE
WERE PLANNING TO TRAVEL TO D.C.
WITH THE INTENT TO CAUSE
VIOLENCE.
>> Sean: NOW JUST HOW DID
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S REMARKS INCITE
AN ATTACK THAT HAS NOW BEEN IN
THE WORKS FOR WEEKS?
TONIGHT WE NEED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT WENT WRONG AT THE
CAPITOL, THIS CAN’T HAPPEN IN
OUR COUNTRY.
BY THE WAY, THOSE THAT TRAVEL TO
WASHINGTON D.C., THOSE INVOLVED
IN THE PLOTTING AND THE PLANNING
AND THE SCHEMING WITH VIOLENT
INTENTIONS, OH, YEAH, WHY DIDN’T
WE KNOW ABOUT IPT?
WHY WEREN’T THEY PREPARED?
SADLY, DEMOCRATS ARE MORE
INTERESTED IN WAGING YET ANOTHER
POINTLESS SMEAR OF FORMER
PRESIDENT IN EXILE DONALD TRUMP.
LET’S HOPE THE TRIAL GOES ON AND
ON FOR WEEKS AND MONTHS.
I HIGHLY RECOMMEND IT, CHUCK.
JUST EXTEND IT OUT, DAY AFTER
DAY, MONTH AFTER MONTH.
LET AMERICA FULLY ABSORB HOW
SHALLOW YOU AND YOU REMEMBER
PARTY ARE.
LET’S LEARN ABOUT THE GLARING
DOUBLE STANDARD AND THE RANK
HYPOCRISY THAT IS ALL OF
WASHINGTON AND ALL OF ITS SWAMP
UGLINESS.
THIS IS NOT, NEVER HAS BEEN A
SERIOUS PROCEEDING.
IT’S A PHONY POLITICAL SHOW
TRIAL.
THERE’S NO JUDGE.
CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS REFUSED TO
PRESIDE OVER THE CASE.
NOW YOU HAVE THAT GUY ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF THE SCREEN OR
RIGHT, THE RIGHT SIDE, ON THE
LEFT FACING THIS WAY, DEMOCRAT
PATRICK LEAHY.
HE WILL PRESIDE.
THE SAME SENATOR WHO IS ALREADY
STATED TRUMP SHOULD BE
CONVICTED.
THERE’S A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL
JURIST, RIGHT?
NOW, ARE WE THE ONLY ONES THAT
SEE WHAT A COMPLETE FARCE, WHEN
A TRAVESTY OF JUSTICE THIS IS?
WHEN A TOTAL COLOSSAL WASTE OF
TAXPAYER MONEY AND TIME.
WE ALSO KNOW WHERE THE SO-CALLED
JURY STANDS.
NEARLY EVERY SENATOR HAS GONE ON
RECORD WITH WHAT THEIR BELIEFS
ARE.
THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN
POLITICAL THEATER.
THE LINES WILL BE SCRIPTED, THEY
WILL BE DELIVERED WITH GREAT
PASSION.
IT WILL BE LIKE A BROADWAY PLAY
THAT YOU DON’T HAVE TO PAY FOR,
NOR DO YOU HAVE TO WATCH.
WE ALREADY KNOW HOW IT ENDS.
ZERO SUSPEND.
IN THE COMING DAYS, YOU CAN
EXPECT A LOT OF MANUFACTURED
LOUD, FAMED PHONY OUTRAGE FROM
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA, HOW DID
THIS HAPPEN?
WHILE IGNORING EVERYTHING THAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID AND DONE
EVEN THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
NONE OF IT WILL MEAN A THING.
IT’S ALL AN ACT FROM A BUNCH OF
SWAMP AND SEWER RAT POLL
SITUATIONS THAT WILL NEVER HOLD
THEMSELVES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
VERY STANDARDS THAT THEY
SANCTIMONIOUSLY SET UP FOR
DONALD TRUMP AND OTHERS.
OF COURSE, IF MR. UNITY, JOE
BIDEN, ACTUALLY WANTED TO BRING
THIS COUNTRY TOGETHER AS HE SAYS
HE DOES AND ACTUALLY EASE
TENSIONS, HE COULD PUT A STOP TO
THIS RIGHT NOW.
THERE’S AN UPSIDE.
THE MORE THEY FOCUS ON HATING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WELL, FRANKLY
HOLD ON TO YOUR WALLETS THAT
MEANS LESS DAMAGE THEY’RE DOING
TO THE COUNTRY BY IMPOSEING THEI
SOCIALIST AGENDA AND RAISING
YOUR TAXES AND FIRING GUYS THAT
WORK ON THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINES AND OTHER OIL AND
ENERGY EXPLORATION AND BUILDING
THE WALL.
THOSE GUYS THAT GOT FIRED.
KEEP GOING, DEMOCRATS.
YOU’RE DOING A GREAT JOB HELPING
AMERICANS.
WHILE WE’RE AT IT, A LONG LIST
OF WITNESSES.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM CALLED.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD IMPEACH HIM A
FEW MORE TIMES.
LET’S MAYBE GO FOR AN EVEN DOZEN
TRUMP IMPEACHMENTS.
JOE IS NEVER GOING TO STAND UP
TO THE RADICALS THAT CONTROL
HIM.
HE WILL NEVER ASK FOR THE UNITY
HE SAYS HE WANTS BECAUSE HE’S
INCAPABLE OF STANDING UP TO HIS
OWN PARTY AND THE MEDIA MOB THAT
CONTROL HIM.
SO BUCKLE UP.
THIS COUNTRY IS ABOUT TO BE PUT
THROUGH HELL OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
GUESS WHAT?
THE DEMOCRATS HE SCREAM, THEY
WILL YELL, THEY WILL RANT AND
RAVE.
THEY WILL USE THEIR PREPARED
SCRIPTS AND THROW ONE LAST TRUMP
TEMPER TANTRUM ALL WITH THE LOVE
OF THE MEDIA MOB AND BIG TECH.
AS MY FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE MARK
SIMONE, RADIO HOST PUT IT, TOO
MUCH IS IMPEACHMENT DAY.
THE DEMOCRATS IMPEACH TRUMP
EVERY FEBRUARY.
IT’S AN ANNUAL EVENT.
LIKE THE GOLDEN GLOBES.
THEY MISSED IT BECAUSE OF THE